[Music]
good afternoon everyone welcome to
Android you might a section my name is
Jane Lynch I'm a product manager in
Android emulator team join me on stage
are Frank and hoi how many people here
have been using android emulator show me
your hands
wow that's great good to see you guys
here today we're going to tell you about
a new feature and show you a few use
case hopefully that would inspire you to
a new way to using android meter to
improve your productivity if you have a
using Android you meter
the first tip for you you can download
Android studio today and try it out
enjoy you mater has always been part of
SDK from version 1 can you believe it is
already 11 years ago I still remember my
first Android app I deal with it with
SDK one top five
Batman enjoy emulator was slow I entered
me to using a lot of physical device but
in the past few years we have been
systematically improve Android emulator
three years ago we build a foundation to
make it much much faster and add the
punch of a feature so it's easier for
you to test application with it two
years ago we add the Google Play Store
support so you can actually test your
application distribution flow n2n last
year we add a snapshot you can actually
easily switch between different systems
day to help you to different tasks
quickly and this year we add the
foldable suppo you can start a help user
to unfold the future with your
application with almost change we are
absolutely focused on three key
principle the first one is fast a good
Yuma later should be fast so we can
treat getting done quickly the second
one a good numerator should be high
fatality
what you mean you can test application
just like it you using physical device
finally a good you later can can be
versatile so we can actually help you
finish different kind a task quickly at
Google we believe faster is better than
slow that's why we start making Android
you might have fast to save your time so
how do we know something is fast obvious
UI is a big part of it because nobody
liked using chunky UI we use in this two
major our department this is I'll show
you how many frame per second a device
control when they run the benchmark
application as you can see enjoy you
mater is slightly faster than pixel to f
0 which means running application and
enjoy beta is pretty fast now in case
you're curious I use in the notebook
have a cocoa CPU 60 keep a brand fresh
storage and the code GPU Frank can you
tell us how we make enjoy beta fast
sure can't Sam so to start out with the
biggest thing that's changed about the
Android emulator versus the emulator
from many years back is we stopped
translating every single instruction of
the guest operating systems at x86 one
at a time so we used to be the case that
you ran an arm Android guest operating
system on an x86 host machine and that
required the emulator to look at every
single instruction and decode them while
translating them to x86 equivalents and
this is actually how most emulators work
these days because of this architectural
mismatch between the guest operating
system CPU architecture and the host CPU
architecture but with the Android
emulator we decided to run x86 on etics
x86 and that gives you a really powerful
technology CPU virtualization which is a
set of hardware extensions for your CPU
that let you simply direct your computer
and run the Android yes
operating systems code directly well
with almost no translation so these
technologies are called hypervisors and
we use hacks among Windows or Windows
hypervisor platform if you're want to
run with hyper-v and on math we use Mac
OS hypervisor framework and a Linux we
use KVM so this lets you run the Android
guest operating system with nearly the
same CPU performance as your host
machine next Android to give a brief
better background does almost all of its
hardware rendering operations using the
OpenGL ES or Vulcan api's previously we
used to run these graphics api's in the
Android guest operating system using the
CPU to render
while these api's are meant to be used
with hardware GPUs however hardware GPUs
is now the default setting for the
Android emulator and has been for quite
some time and we recently started
supporting the Vulcan and OpenGL ES 3.0
and Android q we do this by leveraging
GPU virtualization techniques that let
you use the full power of your host GPU
in order to run Android emulator that's
great thanks so during the development
process I you actually interact with
Android device quite open for example
you're testing the app that you install
in education all those interaction is
basically thump I enjoy debug bridge to
help you transform data from the enjoy
computer to Android device the way to
measure its performance you can easily
done by pushing a application or a file
to Android device on this chart you show
you enjoy and waiter can actually doing
this much much faster Frank can you show
us what is that sure so if you're using
o go back to the slides sure if you're
using a real device you often need to
connect it with USB and USB contains a
few complications here and there so
need a USB cable upon USB cables USB T
or three USB drivers that work well with
your Mac OS or Windows system especially
and depending on your device it may or
may not support the latest and greatest
USB protocols that are fast after using
the emulator everything takes place on
your host machine all of your ATV pushes
and all that they basically talk through
a virtual TCP connection over shared
memory so you're essentially limited by
your host machines disk i/o when you're
transferring files over a TV so that's
why we can get a to be push to be so
fast nice great we start a performance
at the bandage you can actually get
thing down faster for example when you
install the education this just show you
later is actually faster for simple
application of course if your world
application is much bigger and so you
might have to save you more time we also
know your memory - quite a lot of thing
on your computer and sometimes you just
need to close entró emulator to do some
other thing well for Android wha he
actually kept a few open our sequence
which you can take for awhile
that's why we add book quick book which
will resume enjoy you meter in the few
second switch you to timeout please
thanks so I'll show you the difference
between a normal boot up of the device
and the emulator so this AVD called cold
boot you can select a cold boot right
now and you see this black screen here
cold boot selected by user and yes we
gotta wait for a while before a Google
logo comes up but have this other AVD
called quick boot where you just press
play I have a previous snapshot saved
here and it's able to just come up right
away while the other emulator is still
in the middle of its boot up cycle and
the quick boot emulator is already
interactive right away so this makes it
really easy to set your device in some
state then you need some more resources
or whatever you close the emulator and
you launch it again really quickly also
this is our most heavyweight hardware
profile the 8 inch foldable and it was
able to launch in much less time than a
cold boot using our snapshots technology
thanks back to the slides
wow that's great ok we also try to look
at what kind of thing enjoy your weather
can do faster than their physical device
for example our friend on a our code
team they love to using Android mater to
test a application but just like me they
are lazy they don't want to do many or
test every time they change their
application that's why they add a new
feature called AR Michael this allows
you to play back a preset uh breaker so
you can do sanity test quickly and
precisely switch to demo please thanks
Sam so for those of you who went to the
keynote today there is some really cool
a our demos right and it kind of looked
like that you really needed a real
physical device in order to develop and
test a our apps however on the emulator
we've been working with the eric worre
team to enable you to test and develop a
arcore's apps without needing a physical
device we use we call this the virtual
scene camera it is a virtual camera
device that exposes a virtual
environment this virtual environment has
textures that can be picked up by a our
core tracking algorithms and thus can
function largely to the needs of your AR
core application but recently we've
added a feature called AR core macros
this is because when you're running this
referral scene camera you might end up
doing a lot of repetitive motions like
maybe resetting to their initial
precision which we can do now with a
button press or tracking a horizontal
plane in order to get the tracking plane
to show up so we can place your AR core
models notice that while the playback is
going on the camera is changing its view
point according to the macros
instructions and while that is going on
all the right sensor signal
are sent to the guests so that your app
will think that it's in a real
environment Thanks
now back to slides thank you I think I
want to add on that one is if you look
at the mobile devices the powerful
mobile devices actually interact with
the world that mean you need to do a lot
of test manually and we try to explore
if Android emulator can help you on that
this is just as a starting point in a
past few months we have been working on
4G mobile which Polish Android emulator
in a new memories we actually improve
the efficiency for enjoy later for
example when devices on the charge Mart
Play Store can automatically update
application whenever there's a new
version available this is absolutely one
of a key reason Android you made
attacking a lot of CPU and consume a lot
of power as you can see on a chart that
right now to avoid avoid this the team
actually properly enabled battery mode
by default which will eliminate
application auto arte and the background
task as you can see it up all night but
don't worry you can still turn on
application auto update whenever you
like it just switch to a c-more yes let
me hand this over to Hawaii to tell you
more thank you Sam
so we have just talked about how do we
make the emulator nice and fast the next
thing that we need in an Emirati is well
actually we need to trust it otherwise
there is very little point in you
testing anything on the emulator so the
team have done a lot of work to make
sure that the behavior of the emulator
is the same or very similar to the
physical device so what are three things
that we have done let's go through them
the first thing is we start off with the
same code base as a physical device and
when we say the same code base
we don't mean half a stack we mean the
whole stack and that includes the
hardware abstraction layer as well as
the init Linux kernel
in addition assem and frank mentioned
earlier we've made it super fast for
Windows Mac and Linux by paying a lot of
attention to performance so that you can
get the same feel using emulator as a
physical device so ok fine you know
you've done the code but that's all good
developers do we test it so we are now
running over 900,000 compatibility tests
and these are the same tests that pass
with your fiscal phone so your fiscal
phone passed these tests and the
emulator passed the same test and you
might go yeah oh you know 900,000 big
number what does it actually mean can
you give me a concrete example where
this makes a difference so this is one
of the tests that the previous
generation of the Android emulator have
failed when you are displaying a y UV
image instead of displaying the blue
ones you ate
actually we sneekly feeding blue 1 3 2
and hope that you didn't notice well you
may not notice it from this screen but
your integrations has wood and a lot of
integrations has actually failed because
of this and why is that when we go
through the code base these kinds of
things were in it we basically run one
set of code if it is a fiscal device and
we run a completely different set of
code if it is running in the emulator so
the team worked diligently and went
through all the code color within
Android to take these car codes out so
the result is when you specify blue one
to eight you can be sure that it is
giving you blue one to eight and if this
doesn't convince you maybe this state
will from the first of August 2019 as we
all know when you're submitting a new or
update to the Google Play Store you will
need to submit a 64-bit version and if
you haven't got a 64
devised to Han well the Android emulator
is your friend woohoo
so we have done testing you know we've
done our code base how about things that
you normally find on a physical phone
the team-up does such a good job that
Google Play Store actually now trust us
to basically put this store on our phone
and what this means is you can actually
truly test the app and to end not just
installing it and run through the flow
within your app but through all the
things that are around the app as well
so a typical end-to-end testing scenario
might start with you know an ad or a on
a website on another app when you click
through you can it will actually take
you to Google to the Google Play Store
and you can install the app right there
after that you can sign in with your
Google account or any of the social
network that your app may support
because you can now install those social
network apps on the emulator if your app
support in-app purchase you can also
test in-app purchase in the emulator
itself and last but not least all of us
want our apps go viral you can now share
your app within your within the emulator
and pass that flow as well so this is
truly end-to-end testing woohoo we heard
a couple claps excellent so we've built
at the emulator superfast and hopefully
what convinced you is you know we've
done a lot work in getting back your
trust on the fatality of the emulator
how about how does it actually fit into
your workflow so let's talk about the
versatility of the emulator itself my
own personal favorite feature is
snapshot how many of you have basically
install an app run through the flow and
you realize oh actually you tested again
which means uninstalling your app and
then basically reset up the entire thing
again show me your hands
yay okay so this feature is for you I
don't think you have done all your setup
steps you can just tell the emulator to
save a snapshot and when you're ready to
test again from exactly that particular
point you can just click on the one
button and basic get back right back to
that point can we switch to the laptop
please and Frank will demonstrate this
for us over to you thanks Howie
so I'm gonna demonstrate this little
thing where oftentimes snapshots can be
useful for when you want to put your
device in a particular state that is
easy to get back to this is especially
going to be an issue in new foldable
devices where split-screen may be more
prominent so the demonstrate split
screen first I'll show you how to set it
up I'm going to start this multi window
playground app that does different
things depending on your split screen
settings I'm gonna activate split screen
by pressing the app icon and selecting
split screen so now we have another
window pane in which we can potentially
launch a different application now when
you're testing this multi window app one
of the things that might happen is you
might launch an unreasonable activity
and now when you launch that the system
has no choice but to cancel split screen
mode and put you in this fixed aspect
ratio mode right here and now if you
want to retest that original scenario
you need to click through what I just
did again but with the snapshots once
you have saved your device in a state
where that staked out you like you can
click play down here and it will load
the snapshot and I guess it's still
loading but yeah that is live demo yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
load it and then it's in the state that
you were using before and you can then
pretty easily set up many other states
here and also change the name of your
snapshot in every
thing so that's cool all right back to
slides cool thank you Frank
so in that scenario you might argue hey
you know it's just two steps you split
the screen but as many of you who have
raised your hand before you know you
might spend five minutes setting up your
app to a particular state before you go
on and test and what I usually do as
well is I will actually run through the
flow of my app and take several
snapshots around along the way which
saves me a ton of time when I want to
retest a particular bug fix or when I
want to just add a new feature at a
particular place and I can go right back
in so a perform step shot and we have
done a lot of testing so now is your
turn and what's better than running one
test running multiple tests at the same
time so another feature that the enter
emulator support is having multiple
instances running different tests at the
same time another way that I use this is
to test the same app on different screen
configurations and this doesn't just
work for the phone form-factor
it also works for large screen and photo
bows as well and another thing about the
emulator is quite often you know you
have different devices available in
different geographies and in this very
case photo bows are actually pretty hard
to get even when you're working in
Google so what happened with the
foldable at a moment is I have to say my
first taste affordable and testing my
own app on volleyball is actually on the
Android emulator so I strongly encourage
you to take a look and I'm sure that you
have got many more questions about this
new form factor and also the larger
screen apps so we have got a special
session today at 5 p.m. where you can
check out the latest best practice about
building 4 foldable and large screen I
strongly recommend that you attend our
session so we have 10 different tests
running at the same time you know we
have different screen configuration
tests
what about other things you can do with
multiple instances of the emulator
another one my favorite is basically
running different instances but running
different API levels I'm sure that a lot
of you will go through the behavior
change page of every single Android
release and find out oh you have changed
this let me test that this makes it
super-easy to test the different API
levels such as in this example the share
screen have been changed in android q so
you can now test it right next to an
Oreo device or emulator rather so Frank
can you show us how this could be done
the different types of testing indeed
let's switch a lot of things like so
there are many different things that you
can do with multiple instances of
emulators and there are different
degrees so the first one which we
introduced recently is the rage or run
more than one instance of the same AVD
note that previously you needed to
create more than one AVD if you wanted
to run more than one emulator in
parallel well now you don't have to I
have a terminal open with a script to
launch multiple instances of the same
AVD called launch multi instance Sh
now you'll notice that this command line
is pretty typical except for the fact
that you have this new command line flag
here read-only and the AVD name is the
same in both cases now why is this
significant well read-only will
essentially let you launch more than one
instance of an AV D at the same time so
when you launch this script it will
launch both of them in the background in
addition if you add the read-only option
and you're booting off of a quick boost
nap shot you're only going to restore to
that previous snapshot and discard all
of the changes to the snapshot once you
exit so once you launch it again you're
going to be in the same exact state that
you started with when you last saved the
quick boot snapshot I will demonstrate
now
so this is actually two emulators and
they're all running independently and if
we look in say let's clear the terminal
a B devices we have two devices and with
we can run integration tests as if we
actually had two devices so for example
if I try to run this instrumentation
test here the adb shell am instrument it
can run on parallel on both devices at
the same time so one test is running on
one device and a different test is
running on the other device so you can
get kind of test charting pretty easily
one last thing to mention about resuming
these AVD clones from the same snapshot
is that their RAM is shared until it's
written it's called copy-on-write so
this is also using less RAM than if you
started to independent a VDS so that's
the same a VD in sense but what if you
are testing multiple screen
configurations
well let's launch a normal screen
configuration and one of the new
foldable ones let's see
and if we run the Santa tracker and the
emulator with normal screen
configuration it comes with a particular
layout however if you launch the
foldable emulator and then inside that
emulator you launch the same app you can
often get a different layout so running
multiple emulator screen configurations
this way lets you really quickly test
multiple screen configurations quickly
and since this is a foldable device I
have to also demonstrate the folding
feature so with a foldable device the
app layout will change a lot if you fold
and unfold and so the foldable virtual
devices give you a quick way to test
this all right so that's four different
screen configurations what about
different API levels in launch SDK
compat I will be launching two emulators
one of them is an API 27 Oreo and
another one is a cue image so once we
once we launch them both of them are in
read-only mode so once you can integrate
this into your CI pipelined all the
changes are discarded on exit so you can
launch it the same way to next time
without wiping any data or installing
any apps or restoring any state anyways
let's see sharing shortcuts test test
that sharing app that I was showing
earlier on both of these API levels in
parallel and we can indeed get one of
the tests to fail and one of the tests
to succeed depending on the API level so
there you have it multiple instances
they will let you shard your test with
the same AVD let you run multiple
screens configurations in parallel and
run tests some different API levels in
the same manner all right back to slides
yay isn't that fantastic
so hopefully we have convinced that
convinced you that you should run all
your tests coming in multiple instances
another way they can really help is to
run actually those tests in a hairless
mode so you can save even more memory
and by all counts you save about a
hundred megabyte if you're running it in
hairless mode Frank can you show us
indeed let's fish your laptop so one of
the complaints about the emulator we
heard a lot is how hard it was to deploy
in many common continuous integration
continuous delivery pipelines in the
recent versions of the emulator we try
to take a hard look at the emulators
dependencies on the Linux system and try
to strip down as many of them as
possible
starting with removing the usage of UI
libraries so you used to depend on
things like x11 pulseaudio QT but now we
give you the option to run the emulator
in a minimal dependency headless build
so in order to use the headless build
let's see qp3 headless Sh in recent
emulator versions we provided a new
emulator binary called emulator -
headless what this is is a emulator that
doesn't use any UI but still does all of
the rendering and everything else just
as the normal emulator would so that you
can get high fidelity results by making
it and easier to deploy we explicitly
list the libraries on Linux that this
depends on there's only like seven of
them like LDS oh and various essential
things so hopefully we can make this
makes it easier for you to run CI
pipelines with emulators launching this
you'll notice that it's launched but
there's no UI but if we go back to
studio law cat is running everything and
your tests will behave as if there was a
real device there still you just have a
minimal footprint that is easier to
deploy alright thanks back to slides
whoo let's go back to slides please and
I'm sure that a lot of you really want
to find out what's the latest best
practice on building tests Oh apps so on
Thursday 11:30 we've got another session
for you please go there for the latest
information
so we've went through the day-to-day
development using snapshot so you're
having multiple tests running
integration tests or maybe your
continuous integration system running
them okay so after your app launch I am
sorry but in real life you know the
enjoy not responsive and crashes
unfortunately do happen and one of the
ways that I use the emulator is to
basically in conjunction with the Google
Play console so the Google Bay console
you will see the different crashes or
Android not responsive being divided
into different sections one is you know
potentially your own app version another
one is the different devices that are
experiencing these car problems and then
third is a different API levels and you
might also want to have a look at the
kind of user feedback and you know where
the positive or negative depending on
the device as well and this is a kind of
workflow that I would go through so the
first thing that we do is I will have a
look at you know are there any
particular device studies causing a lot
of crashes or injure or not being
responsive and if it is I would look up
what is the screen density is that hdpi
or is it other different screen size or
density once I get that I will launch an
emulator that matches that and just do a
sanity test that will be that's usually
very quick much much faster than me kind
of going down to the device lab and
checking a device out if it's not that
the next thing that we do is to look at
the API level and see whether the
crashes is actually caused by
differences in behavior of the different
API levels
well the emulator we think is of very
high quality there are always instances
where you do need to go back to physical
device but hopefully what we have done
here in this session is to convince you
the emulator is actually your first port
of call in this diagnostic and to hear
more from the Google Play team about how
to use the latest Android fighters to
improve the quality of your apps and
games on Thursday at 2:30 we have a full
session to go through all the new
features and existing features so with
that let me hand it back to Sam thence
the whole um Frank so that's a lot of
information to remember and I bet you
guys remember they know right just
kidding so now let's recap first enjoy
emulator is pretty fast now so you can
actually get get your tests done quickly
secondly enjoy numerator is pretty close
to a physical device so we can do most
of a test with it with confidence
finally enjoy you mater it's pretty flat
for you will help you to validate
different API different screen
comparation quickly so with that we leap
enter you later can be your go-to device
for Education Department one thing we
like about Android is an open platform
just like internet permission list
innovation is possible that's why we
want to build entry meter to help the
new opportunity only possible because
user like you actually create the new
way to help the user so hopefully this
will help you to find a new way to using
android meter to improve your
productivity thank you for coming and
enjoy the rest of i/o
[Music]
you